we begin tonight with an exclusive
interview with someone who knows a thing
or two about White House staff shakeups
he was White House chief of staff for
President Trump from January until July
2017 before that he was chairman of the
Republican replica National Committee
and we're pleased to welcome Reince
Priebus right yeah great to be here
there's a lot to learn in this opening
yeah come on so what do you think about
where we are right now I mean the
Republicans we're gonna get to what's
happening on trade but the House
Committee the Intel committee today
announced it's shutting down we're gonna
they didn't find any Russian collusion
the president's been saying this
consistently what's your take well you
might recall in the summer about six
seven months ago there was starting to
bubble up a call among political leaders
party leaders and there our party that
the Intel Committees of both the House
and the Senate should shut down because
the Muller probe would be so far
reaching that there was be no need for
these committees to continue subpoenaed
on people and interviewing people it was
actually the president they said no let
these committees do their work so behind
closed doors the president was saying no
let them keep going because I know that
eventually they're gonna issue a report
and the reports going to say there's
there was no collusion we never talked
to the Russians we didn't we didn't
negotiate with these people so the
president actually very confident this
would happen I've never seen it I of
course never spoke to Russians at the
RNC
I've never heard of other people doing
it never talked to people like
Papadopoulos and Carter page so you know
I'm not surprised but I wouldn't want
people to understand that the president
was also behind the scenes quietly
saying let these committees do their
work Maxine Waters was on another
network tonight and this is just so
hilarious we had to play it for you
let's watch who would believe Nunez was
working in a credible way to find out
what took place as a matter of fact he
was simply a messenger boy for the
president running up in the middle of
the night trying to prove that Obama for
example had
our tap the president and so they can
conclude whatever they want to they
weren't doing anything to begin with it
was not a credible investigation so
that's what the Democrats take us is a
messenger boy I don't know if that's a
very nice can be their take through the
midterms in through 2020 the problem in
the midterms of course is that you've
got marginal races that are in place so
you know eighty percent of the districts
are either ninety percent Republican or
ninety percent Democrat there are no
real marginal races others I mean about
twenty two to twenty to get into the
pencil eraser so this type of rhetoric
isn't going to work the impeachment
rhetoric doesn't work in marginal races
these are generally people that want to
see you know Washington work and and in
policy driven type debates is what
you're going to see in those marginal
districts yeah and speaking of them in
on this trade issue and you're you're a
free trader when I hear free trade of
money okay I'm for trade I want trades
great yeah but one hundred and fifty
billion dollar trade deficit with Europe
three hundred sixty billion with China
even with Japan we have a sixty eight
point eight billion dollar trade deficit
the South Korean free trade deal each
year the deficits have grown and grown
and grown so my question is how do you
get leverage with these countries that
are taking us to the cleaner on these
trade but he's getting leverage now is
he not what do President Trump does
which is if you see carefully what he's
doing is he puts the he puts the chips
on a table he puts the the game plan on
the table so people can see it and they
can freaked out about it but then what
he does is systematically he negotiates
each piece so Canada is off the board
Mexico's off the board had a phone call
with the Prime Minister of Australia
over the weekend tweeted out they're off
the board and eventually I think what
he's gonna do is he's gonna put the
issue on the table it's gonna build
negotiate with these countries like he's
always wanted to do one by one by land
we're doing this now this is what I'm
saying the Republican Party's
criticizing him and he got the EU in
Japan two days ago to say we're standing
against China trade abuses do you think
they ever would have done that with with
light hyzer and will bore us they will
ever never would have done that unless
they were looking at trade tariffs but I
would say this in defense of some you
know I liked your monologue very
intelligent but in defense of part of it
the president choose
is on his own to put people around him
that don't agree with each other a major
major things me so even when I was there
wasn't like you know it's a couple
narratives that were incorrect on this
tariff stuff this wasn't something that
the president suddenly came up with and
then oh my god he just went with the
tariffs out of nowhere this was
something that was debated from before
the inauguration he wanted this steel
and aluminum tariffs since before the
inauguration we debated it week after
week after week and he got pretty ticked
off a few times at the staff and said
hey where are my tariffs he's a patient
I've been well right and it's naughty
but that's what makes him who he is
right but this was not send the other
this was not something that just came
about who he's been debating it forever
the other thing is it's what President
Trump is to put Wilbur Ross and Gary
Cohen and Bob light hyzer and Stephen
Miller ala nabina also people that don't
agree right I mean some white houses
have the same species of people Oh
everyone's the same he has no problem
putting natural predators together but
and let them bring their a-game and
fight it out and then he makes it to see
I really respect that and I want to get
into this Abed said no I completely
agree with you and I don't I don't mean
to say there shouldn't be debates I
think on some of the core issues at some
point you do have to just kind of but
he's always gonna go with this yeah I
mean in the end and he goes it's close
he's gonna go with his gut alright let's
talk about this Pennsylvania district
district is 18 yeah
this is being watched by everybody this
is a district that Trump won big time
big league and now it's really tight
there's gonna it's gonna be redrawn in
November anyway but this is being looked
at as a big bellwether Monmouth came out
with the polls showing the Democrat
thirty three-year-old prosecutor Connor
lamb ahead by a little but you're not so
sure that Democrats could pull this out
yeah III think it's gonna be really hard
for the Democrats to pull this so I
think I think they may be over hyping
this a little bit I think I think the
Republicans are playing is pretty well
by setting expectations that you know
they're that they may lose the here's
what the reality is the you're right the
president one district district by about
20 points today he's up by maybe
anywhere from 10 to 12 or 13 he's right
side up in the district so there's been
a loss of about eight points in that
particular place can
it's matter but what really this is
going to be about people have been
talking about it today is turnout and
what I would explain to people is that
in a district like this if you had a
bowl of popcorn one was Republican one
was Democrat the voters in the
Republican Bowl the popcorns all the way
up to the top and the Democrat ball the
popcorn is about two-thirds of the way
hungry now right you need some silly
thing but here's the thing Republicans
have a full bowl to turnout if they do a
really really poor job and say only
turnout two-thirds and the Democrats do
a great job and and and get every single
person out then they can win but it's
still going to be very deficit I don't
say the data so far has been showing
things trending back to the Republican
over the last few days so I just don't
see how you see that Trump speech in
Pennsylvania and think that that is that
that is mojo I don't care what it says
what's up Todd I wouldn't is the one
thing about it being a referendum on
Trump I think you have to you have to
throw that one out because if Donald
Trump is on the belt today in the
district he'd win restrict so the
question is is the candidate chosen by
the Republican is the turnout and is the
turnout in that district going to make
the difference between the two parties I
think the RNC and the Republican feeling
like I'm going back to 2012 with you at
the RNC getting the murder board out and
see what districts what